Alabama let's read some more about less
we're here with Ryan blazer from testy
home.com we're talking today about a
bunch of invisible toxins in our
environment the chemicals the
fragrances the nonnative EMF we're
talking about products that might be
toxic to us and paint and furniture that
can be toxic to us and I want to talk
about one thing this is is going to
sound
hyperbolic and I try to avoid this type
of superlative or this type of hyperbole
but I think it makes a lot of sense to
talk about this right now we're going to
talk about earthing or grounding for a
moment and so I'm combining the more
about less segment and the added value
segment on this week's podcast because
if I had to name one thing that I've
gotten the most value from in my life
it's Gra grounding at home earthing at
home there's a company called
earthing.com Clint Ober has been on this
podcast we'll put a link to that episode
in the show notes we did an entire
episode about earthing with him now I
have this autoimmune disease which
creates intense inflammation in my body
especially react to certain foods that I
eat but even without food I will often
wake up with just tremendous
inflammation in my body so much so that
there were times a few years ago before
I stumbled into grounding or earthing I
realized that oh wait a minute I don't
think I've really touched the Earth much
over the course of almost 40 years and I
realized that oh these rubber sold shoes
that we're all walking around with have
inadvertently disconnected us from the
earth Rubber Soul shoes were invented in
the late 50s and so since 1960 most of
us have accidentally disconnected from
the Earth from the natural grounding
because before that we would wear shoes
but they would have leather soles and so
you'd still have some level of grounding
some connection to the Earth we took
that away not knowing there might be a
potential downside to that and so I
started walking barefoot on the beach
more I started walking barefoot outside
when I lived in this neighborhood I
would walk through West Hollywood
Barefoot even and I recognized that the
inflammation in my body I started
noticing how less inflamed I became I
said how can I ground more how can I
even ground when I'm sleeping well there
was a way for me to do that I bought a
earthing mat from earthing.com not a
sponsor advertisements suck but it's the
thing I've gotten the most value from I
can say this with very little doubt I
likely would not be here today if it
weren't for the amount of earthing SL
grounding that I've been able to to do
both naturally in natural environments
Barefoot on the beach in the ocean or
just walking barefoot on the grass but
also coupling that with when I'm
indoors having a earthing mat that helps
relieve some of my symptoms and I wanted
to share some of the science behind this
because also Ryan Blazer he illuminated
maybe one shocking
downside to grounding in the home and it
set off all these light bulbs some red
light light
bulbs above my head and I started
thinking like oh wait okay so while
earthing has been tremendously valuable
to me and I've recommended it to many
hundreds of thousands of people on this
podcast and close friends I've given it
to everyone I can because it's helped me
so much and I've seen so many people
benefit from it especially people with
autoimmune diseases a lot of women with
endometriosis or uh people who have
irritable bowel
syndrome the earthing or grounding has
eliminated or radically reduced the
amount of inflammation in their bodies
and now we know why here's an NIH study
called the effects of grounding earthing
on inflammation the immune system wound
healing and prevention and treatment of
chronic inflammatory and autoimmune
diseases Alabama would you read the
abstract from this study and then we'll
put a link to the entire study in the
show notes for folks who want to dive
deep multi-disciplinary research has
revealed that electroly conductive
contact of the human body with the
surface of the Earth grounding or
earthing produces intriguing effects on
physiology and health such effects
relate to inflammation immune responses
wound healing and prevention and
treatment of chronic inflammatory and
autoimmune diseases the purpose of this
report is twofold to one inform
researchers about what appears to be A
New Perspective to the study of
inflammation and two alert researchers
that the length of time and degree
resistance to ground of grounding of
experimental animals is an important but
usually overlooked factor that can
influence outcomes of studies of
inflammation wound healing and
tumorogenesis
specifically grounding in organism
produces measurable differences in the
concentrations of white blood cells cyto
and other Mo molecules involved in the
inflammatory response we present several
hypotheses to explain observed effects
based on the current research results
and our understanding of the electronic
aspects of cell and tissue physiology
cell biology biophysics and biochemistry
an experimental injury to muscles known
as delayed onset muscle soreness has
been used to monitor the immune response
under grounded versus ungrounded
conditions grounding reduces pain and
Alters the numbers of circulating
neuropils and lymphocytes and also
affects various circulating chemical
factors related to inflammation let me
try to put this in layman's terms real
quick Ryan grounding has radically
reduced by inflammation however when you
came over to my house and we were doing
the inspection around my house and you
noticed I have grounding things all over
the place and they plug right into the
wall and while the grounding mat itself
is not electrical it's plugging into an
electrical outlet and in some cases we
may experience electrical interference
with our grounding equipment inside the
house yeah correct yeah I know you said
that perfect well let's let's talk about
the summary of this uh study here we'll
put a link to the entire study in the
show notes so you can read the whole
thing over theminimalists.com
podcast this is the summary of findings
to date Alabama grounding appears to
improve sleep normalize the day night
cortisol Rhythm reduce pain reduce
stress shift the automic nervous system
from sympathetic toward parasympathetic
activation increase heart rate
variability speed wound healing and
reduce blood viscosity a summary has
been published in the Journal of
environmental and public health so those
are a lot of benefits let's and I've
experienced most of these benefits and
I've seen thousands of other people
experience these benefits there's so
many case studies so many studies so
many anecdotal reports which to me are
often some of the most compelling when
you have someone who is just suffering
tremendously like I was with
inflammation and they finally find
something that helps and yet I also want
to be honest that there could be a
potential downside here no downside to
earthing at all you can go outside take
your shoes off put your feet in the
grass or go swim in the ocean or a lake
and the ground in effect of that or the
earthing effect of that is tremendous
however when like I'm plugged into an
earthing mat right now into the wall can
you talk to me about the electronic
interference that might show up when we
are plugging directly into the wall yeah
so there's something called Dirty
electricity this is kind of like a
lamest term but it's talking about line
interference and so on the electrical
wires we have the 60 Cycle um vibration
of the hot wire and that's what's
feeding the electricity into the
different components we plug into it on
top of that though we have interference
and that can come from capacitors Motors
switch mode power supplies uh
refrigerators clicking on and off every
time that happens we got little spikes
it can spikes positive spikes negative
and we call that line interference and
that can U negatively affect affect us
much more than just the electric field
itself that's more biologically active
now the problem is is that the ground
wire runs right next to the neutral wire
and the hot wire all the way back to the
power panel so we get some inductive um
overlay back and forth some inductive
coupling they call it back in the power
panel though the neutral and the ground
wire are bonded together so they're
physically touching each other so
whatever is going to be on the neutral
wire can also show up on the ground wire
from there it's grounded typically to
water pipe or it's ground Ed into the
ground itself with a ground rod so even
though we are physically connected to
Earth and there is an electrical
connection through Earth we also have on
top of that small fluctuations of
current small dirty electricity if you
will now when we connect ourselves to
that those small fluctuations can also
enter onto the body which we measured at
your house with a meter showed how even
when you're touching it versus not
touching it or when it's plugged in that
we're measuring these these small
vibrations dirty electricity getting
onto the body and what what's the
problem with that the problem is that we
uh those inter those fluctuations can
biologically affect us and so what you
were telling me yesterday is that
perhaps for me the benefits outweigh the
cost however there is also a way to be
grounded in your home to extend an
extension to the Earth and bypass the
electrical system can you talk a bit
about that right you know and again it
comes back to ancestrally how were
things 500 years ago everybody walked
around on the ground made with moxin or
sandals we had dirt floor um we were
touching the ground a lot more laying on
the floor sleeping on the ground and so
the Earth itself has a resonance called
the Schuman frequency it's somewhere on
7 Hertz and it's it's got that
Electrical uh vibration to it now our
bodies are in tune with that our body's
resonate with that and so when we're
physically touching the Earth our
electrons will neutralize and we're more
in tune with that the heartbeat of the
earth so to speak so that's good and
that's positive and that's where all
these benefits come from so ultimately
we want to be connected with the Earth
as much as possible and we do that by
physical connection now we're kind of
cheating it a little bit or skipping it
a little bit when we plug into the
electrical because that has to travel
through the whole circuitry of the house
through the power panel and then go to
the box
from the ground on its Journey all the
way back to us it's picking up the
interference from the circuits of the
house and that's where uh it's we still
get the benefit of of grounding you're
earthing we're still connected to Earth
but we're getting all that interference
on top of it so it' be much better to
place our own grounding rod in the
ground away from the electrical system
and just don't tie into the electrical
system at all this is not a good idea to
tie into the electrical grid of our
house if we can can avoid it if we can
physically connect to Earth it's better
if you can't plug into use the outlet
and if and see how you feel some people
feel worse some people feel a lot better
and it all depends on how much
interference is on the line and
depending on where you are in the
country of the world some places have a
lot of interference some places have
small interference so um plug it in and
see how you feel but you're still going
to get the benefits from the earthing
you just have the added um line exposure
on top of it the dirty electricity so
what I'm doing in my house short term is
I'm literally running a grounding rod
out the window into the ground and then
connecting that to the mat that I have
on my bed or the mat that I have on my
chair at my desk or you can wherever
like I'm sitting on a grounding earthing
that right now and then for our added
value Alabama you want to bring those
patches over here to me so the easiest
way to do this by the way is you don't
have to have some elaborate pad or a big
you you know TK you have one for your
mattress now and know Sean Danny and
Alabama they all have one on their
mattress and you don't have to go that
route cuz that's several hundred dollar
to buy that you can get literally
grounding patches put one or two on your
feet you know on the bottom of your feet
because that is where we really absorb
those uh uh negative electrons right
from from the earth and so you can
ground yourself in bed at night or just
when you're sitting on the couch and you
got your blue blocking glasses on and
you're you're watching your uh uh old
1998 um uh uh NBA Finals
reruns because you're a real masochist
um and you can ground that way and you
can plug right into the outlet but I am
now going to just run the ground rod
right out the window and this is how
Clint oer who started earthing.com
started anyway when he started doing
these tests
it wasn't plugging in there was no way
to plug into the the grounded Outlet he
just ran a grounding rod out the window
and then tied a little wire around his
toe and said oh I sleep better when I am
grounded it's like an extension cord to
the Earth so I'm going to do that short
term long term I want to wire the house
so that I have a few Outlets
strategically placed throughout the
house so I can plug right into them and
they're completely separate from the
electrical system at least 24 in away
from any of the electrical wires so I'm
not getting any of that dirty
electricity any of that interference but
I'm still getting all the benefits from
grounding or earthing do you have
anything to add to that no I mean you
did that beautifully you laid it out
perfect yeah so the grounding patches
have helped me out a lot uh you can find
them at earthing.com again not an ad
advertisement suck I I pay for my own
patches as well but but uh they do such
a great job with the products they
create and Clint is independently
wealthy that he doesn't need to like
sell you a bunch of products um what he
did is he realized there was a huge hole
in the marketplace there were a lot of
people who were selling so-called
grounding equipment it just wasn't very
reliable or didn't work well or it
disintegrated pretty quickly and he said
I'm want to find a better way to do that
so birthing has really helped me and
I've seen it help a lot of people with
autoimmune condition but I've seen it
help people also who are just like ah my
sleep's a little bit off and what does
it say here Alabama it moves it reduces
stress shifts the nervous system from
sympathetic toward parasympathetic
increases heart rate variability which
is really important something you can
track speeds wound healing that's
something else that was so fascinating
in this study they have pictures of
people who have a wound and then they
ground the wound by putting a couple
patches right next to the wound
and it's like Wolverine the way that
these people heal and it's so shocking
to me that we don't see more of this and
I think we will in about a decade or
less we'll start to see hospitals using
earthing techniques in conjunction with
traditional Western medicine to speed up
healing so that people recover much more
quickly I hope you enjoyed that
highlight from the minimalist private
podcast if you'd like another highlight
check out this video if you'd like to
watch the minimal episode check out this
video or if you'd like to dive deep into
full episodes of the minimalist private
podcast head on over to patreon the link
is in the description your support keeps
our podcast and YouTube channel 100%
advertisement free